want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn from an
inspiring story that just
might change your life
what i learned ultimately my dad was the
president of the national association
for self-esteem
most people probably don't even know
there is that and he was one of the
first authors of chicken soup for the
soul so for anybody that's
probably above 35 they would know that
but the power of positive thinking never
resonated with
me and when i was young and i was 18
years old and drop out of college and i
was diagnosed with an initial diagnosis
of cancer and it turned out to be
shingles and a number of other things
i did start to understand quickly that
well i don't know if positive thinking
works all the time
and that the data is anecdotal i do know
that negative thinking does work
and it works negatively and one of the
things is i would start at alabama and i
would start with the jacksonville
jaguars and i'd start with the miami
dolphins
i started to realize and even looking
back to a young age
that nobody wants to be told to be
positive
that positive thinking is probably the
number one reason this
industry has not grown in my 44 years of
living
positive thinking in many cases repulses
people
you're telling me to be positive and i'm
going through a divorce you're telling
me to be positive and i threw three
interceptions
you're telling me to be positive and i
gotta deal with this president you're
telling me to be positive and i got this
current situation
you're telling me to be positive and i
got this health situation so then what's
the alternative
well the alternative has always been
negative so how's negativity
carried well is it your internal
thoughts well if you're dealing with
trying to change internal thoughts then
you got to go to affirmations and you
got to go to imagery you got to go to
visualization
very difficult skills well we started to
look at
the externalization well if somebody
says something out loud
it's 10 times more powerful than if they
think it
and then as we started to study the data
particularly data that was just
reinforced by christine porath from
georgetown
and harvard that negativity is a
multiple
of four to seven times more powerful
than positivity
so think about that if i say something
out loud it's 10x
if it's negative it's four to seven
times more powerful
so when i say negative things out loud
it's
40 to 70 times more likely that that
will
happen or cause a result that won't be
good for me
than if i just didn't say anything so as
we were going into our second year at
alabama we were going into our first
year at florida state and we were
ultimately going into our second year at
the university of georgia
we made a bet what if we could just get
our players to not say stupid things out
loud
what if we could just do that not teach
any element of positive thinking
but eliminate conversations about the
heat complaining about coaches
complaining about circumstances
complaining about situations
verbalizing negativity but we weren't
going to lie to them and say
hey be positive we just taught them the
data and then what we did was
some of the things that you you noticed
in the book the stories in and around
negativity are incredible
tell us some bill buckner was one that
took my breath away
so so billy buckner who just passed away
recently was an incredible
eight-time gold globe a great baseball
player for
the boston red sox well he made a
mistake
in sports that would be one of the
biggest sport bloopers in history and in
1986
he let the game-winning run score on a
ground ball through his legs
that ultimately would give the mets the
world series
now i was just watching an espn e60
jeremy shop
story and i saw an interview that was
done in 1990
that resurfaced in 1995 where buckner
was interviewed 12 days before the world
series and he said you know
the dreams are to win you know to win
the world series and the nightmare would
be for me to let the game-winning run
score on a ground ball through my legs
you know and then ultimately that's
exactly what would happen now
by saying that out loud what did he do
he didn't make it happen
but he increased the probability and
this is what i want people to understand
your internal thoughts
are all over the place i want to push on
that
do you think that he makes it more
likely because it's
going to subtly influence his behavior
or because you're talking to some
magical deity that then says well you
said it and so i'm gonna make it happen
i think that what he did is a
subconscious plant
by verbalizing it and knowing that it's
ten times more powerful
he's planting it in his subconscious
he's not he doesn't want it to happen
but it becomes something that's
ultimately on his mind
and he gave it more power by verbalizing
it so we both grew up in tacoma
and there used to be a thing called
toastmasters i don't know if you
remember toastmasters but
toastmasters was a local regional and a
national
speaking group for anybody that wanted
to get better at speaking
well my dad had gone to a toastmasters
early on and heard one of the most
successful magazine entrepreneurs in the
world speak
he comes back and tells me i just had a
chance to hear one of the most
successful magazine entrepreneurs in the
world
speak and he said when are you taking
your s.a.t i said i'm taking it next
year
he said well this guy was failing out of
high school he was struggling he was
raised by a single mom in the midwest
but he promised his mother he would take
a test called the s.a.t
so he takes the s.a.t in may's junior
year doesn't expect anything
get to score back in june now the s.a.t
which i don't know how many
your population know but it's it's a
standardized test with the math part and
a verbal part
both are scored out of 800 points well
this guy takes it he's bombing he's
failing out of school he doesn't expect
anything as he's telling the story of
toastmasters
well he gets a 1480 out of 1600.
so he stunned right that would be for
the smart people that listened to your
problem
yeah right cognitive dissonance so i got
a 900 on my sats just to give people a
friend right and i got a 10
90 and i got a 10 10. right i was just
hey four digits it was a miracle
right and and but it's a hard test and
it you know it's a variety of different
things so
he gets the score and his mother doing
what any mother would do
knowing her kid says did you cheat right
she knows her son
and he said i swear to god i tried to
cheat but the way the numbers were and
the scantrons and the bubbles you
couldn't cheat
so she says you mean to tell me you
really got that score he said yeah i got
the score
so he's stunned tom so as my dad's
telling me the story i'm like okay
so he says all right so what he decides
is because he
realizes he's smart and he's going into
his senior year he says i'm going to go
to class
now he starts to go to class he doesn't
hang out with who he did when he didn't
go to class
all right teachers see him in class and
they said hey maybe
franklin pierce maybe we missed the boat
on this kid so they start to treat him
differently
well as the guy would tell the story he
graduates goes to a community college
goes on to wichita state goes under the
ivy league and becomes this massively
successful magazine entrepreneur so i
said okay
well the guy was always smart he just
needed a standardized test to unlock it
my dad said no
that's not the story this is what i want
you to understand
he said 12 years after all this guy's
success he gets a letter in the mail
from princeton new jersey doesn't think
anything about it the next day his wife
says you're going to open it
he opens it true story turns out the
s.a.t board
will periodically review their test
taking procedures and the policies
the year he took the test he was one of
13 people
sent the wrong s.a.t score his actual
score was a 740
out of 1600. and he said people think my
whole life changed when i got to 1480.
but what happened my whole life changed
when i started acting like a 1480
and what does a 1480 do he goes to class
well this is one of the first stories i
would share when i had my opportunity at
alabama or florida state or georgia
so a your language is powerful but
number two your behavior
is way ahead of your success and so many
people let their feelings
dictate what they do as opposed to throw
your behavior out there
russell wilson's 510 he shouldn't be
playing pro football
but he behaves like the best quarterback
in the country
and he's done that since before he was
at that level
and then his feelings and emotions and
his skill caught up to that behavior
i think the lesson my dad was trying to
teach me ultimately was in addition to
my language
what i do not how i feel about my past
is
going to determine who i am in the
future if you want to see the one-on-one
i did with trevor that will change your
mindset check out the video right there
next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there but i think the one thing evan
that we're always focusing on is
performance not
outcomes what are you doing
to help people